I want to think about all of the
different ways we can represent value in
the number twenty twenty-one point three
so one is just look straight up at the
place values this two is in the tens
place so it literally represents two
tens so this is equal to 22 times ten
this one is literally equal to 1 its 1 1
and then this 3 is 3/10 so plus 3/10 but
now I want to rearrange or regroup the
value in these places so for example I
could take 1 from the ones place and
give it to the tenths place so let's see
how that would work so we're going to
take 1 away from the ones place and so
it's going to become a zero and we're
going to give it to the tenths place
and what we're going to see is that
that's going to make the tens place into
13 into 13 tenths now does that actually
make sense that I took one from here and
it essentially added 10 to the tenths
place
well let's rewrite what this represents
so we still have two tens so this is
still going to be two tens now we have
plus zero ones plus zero ones and we're
essentially wanted to write that that
that one that we took away from the ones
place in terms of tenths so if we were
to write this in terms of tents it would
be ten tenths plus the three tents that
were already there
plus three tenths and so this is going
to be equal to 13 tenths let me write
that down so this is equal to 20 this is
that's the color you can't see this is
equal to 20 plus 0 ones so two tens plus
zero ones plus 13 tens plus 13 tens
let's do another example with this exact
same number so once again 21 21 point 3
21 point 3 and I'll write it out again
this is equal to 20 plus one plus one
we'll do that in the purple color plus
one plus three tenths plus three over
two
now I could take one from the tens place
so that this only becomes this becomes
just one and what do I do with that ten
well let's say I give let's say with
that 10 I give 9 of it to the ones place
so I give 9 of it to the ones place so
that this becomes 10 and I still have
one left over and I give it to the
tenths place so that's going to become
13 over 10 13 over 10 so what did I just
do
well I could rewrite this let me be
clear what I did this is the same thing
as this is the same thing as 1 plus 9
which you let me write it this way 1
plus which I'll write 1 plus 9 plus 1
that's obviously the same thing let me
be for 10 plus 9 10 plus 9 plus 1 is the
same thing as 20 and we're going to have
and of course we have what we have in
our ones place plus 1 plus 3/10 and what
I want to do is I want to take this 9
the 9 that I took from the tens place
give it to the ones place and I'm going
to take this one that took from the tens
place and give it to the tenths place so
1 is the same thing as 10 over 10 and so
you have if you when you regroup this
value you get this as being equal to 10
plus 9 plus 1 is 10 and then 10 tens
plus 3/10 is 13 tenths so that's all
that happened here I changed the value
in the places I took 1/10 away so I'm
only left I had two 10s now I only left
with 1/10 and that extra 10 of value I
regrouped it I gave 9 to the ones place
so 1 plus 9 is 10 and then I gave one to
the tenths place so 1 plus 3/10 is the
same thing as 13 tenths